vous allez m'aider voilà ce matin il y
avait eu un à la banque je devais venir
et je suis arrivé trop tard pour avoir
un témoignage donc vous dites vous avez
tout vu
j'ai rien vu moi parce que j'aurais pris
de l'argent avec ça m'aurait rendu
service alors attention top c'est parti
c'est ici à 10h ce matin que a eu lieu
sanglant heureusement nous avons le
témoin numéro 1 de l'affaire alors
comment ça s'est passé
ils sont partis comme ça au courant ils
étaient combien 3 sur une moto 3 sur une
moto non on n'y croit pas une seconde
faut que ce soit crédible là le hold-up
qui a eu ce matin
pour le journal
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de justement
de l'augmentation de la recrudescence
est excessif ah oui alors donc vous
vous étiez là bien sûr pendant les faits
il s'était combien
ou qui
j'étais combien quoi les malfaiteurs
[Musique]
et alors donc vous avez fait quand même
un acte de bravoure puisque vous avez
essayé de d'arrêter un des malfaiteurs
j'attendais le moment de faire encore
et donc là c'est un peu grâce à vous si
on a arrêté un des malfaiteurs
et donc vous lui avez enlevé la cagoule
j'en ai vu un blanc trois noirs
je crois qu'ils ont sauté dessus et ils
sont barrés là regardez la caméra vous
dites que vous êtes d'accord pour passer
à la télé je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord complètement pour passer à la
télé pour passer à la télé et je suis un
gros menteur
en direct du 18e avec le héros du jour
[Musique]